going up and and not only do I do shoes
though so I'm big in the football
Community also so I sell cleats black
back flaps mouthpieces gloves you know
and that's when I'm trying to get my
partners on like bro well because you
are for people who don't know you're not
just big in the football I mean you're
kind of one of those guys when it comes
to the youth football in La it's a it's
a the new generation it's a couple of
guys and you're coaching you're you have
teams under you or you're helping
develop these kids like um first of all
how did that even like get started
because I mean we always hear Snoop you
know who's kind of the guy who like we
look to in that world but like you've
been on it for so Snoop is the kind of
guy that looked up to like
my dad you know my dad coached football
and bass and people from just different
places we all looked up to somebody and
then you got to think like Snoop was
around when I was a kid coaching youth
football his kids was around Rolling
Heights Raiders so we would see
that and I never thought I was to be a
rapper back then you know I'm saying I
was a football player right I played
football played basketball baseball so I
was just an athlete my Pops I seen the
way my pops
um ventured off to this and it kept him
out the way it kept him my pops had a
free mind when football season came you
know what I'm saying so this kept my
pops alive nice like damn this thing
really want to coach football these kids
what you seeing this and it's really fun
you know what I'm saying and that was my
feeling too right it's fun man it's
fulfilling and I'm like giving back in
my own way and you know these kids don't
know me as Joe Moses they know me at
Coach Joe you know what I'm saying and I
started my own chapter I just went off
on the limb first and foremost I put in
work with the chapter I grew up playing
with you know I'm definitely big on
loyalty so I went back to the same
chapter I grew up playing with Wow and
it was my family still was running the
chapter and um
I stayed there for like five or six
years and we didn't have our different
differences it's just I wanted something
different and they was a little bit
older and they didn't see my vision and
then I started my own chapter I didn't
hate I didn't do anything I just you
know got Their Blessings you know what I
wanted you know we going different ways
and how the vision supposed to look I
didn't put in work these last five years
let me just go in my own way and I'm
gonna start a chapter but I'm gonna
still be in the same league can I get
y'all blessings they gave me the
blessings I went on started the LA
Chiefs and the rest is history I put in
the work the first two years we took ass
whoopings and people laughed at us I
came in the room Hey Joe what you want
to do
um I bet 100 push-ups we whoop y'all ass
whoo I'm like hey I'm like that okay I
took my ass whoopings the first two
first year I took my ass whoopings and
Snoop
then next year was pandemic pandemic I
still play football um
at the pandemic we whooped everybody out
we went we traveled we played travel
ball we went
um Vegas we went to Arizona we went to
San Francisco we went to the Bay Area
Sacramento we went to Texas we played
like real football you know what I'm
saying so I got that experience we ended
up being a ranked team and then
the next year Snoop opened back up
because Snoop wasn't opening up in
pandemic they opened back up and the
rest is history you beat Snoop yeah yeah
yeah you know what's up you know what's
up and we played we played on the 17th
that that Super Bowl game we played the
first game of the season against new
team
because snoop's not like you're a little
bit more Hands-On at this point than
Snoop is right because snoop's got so
much [ __ ] going on yeah yeah pretty you
were like yo I'd love to come to the
club but I have a game this time this
time this time yeah sure you coaching
because for people who don't know so
like if you have a chapter is it like
within that chapter there's a team for
each age group yeah so we got so my
chapter got seven teams we got six you
we got eight you we got two Au teams we
got a nine you we got a 10 you we got 11
you and a 12 you and on those uh uh I
think out of all those teams I coach on
four teams damn I coach 9u 10U 11U and
12u and so you're busy and and I I mean
I'm a president my one of my best
friends is the coach on six you and 8U
so he went down from coaching on my team
the coach and he was successful last
year we won three Champions three
championships last year your chapter
yeah we went we went to we won two
Nationals last year and we've we've just
like we got National ranked teams like
we've beaten national rank number one in
the nation team so I got about four
teams in my chapter that's ranked
nationally that's crazy you know what
I'm saying like number one in the nation
number number three in the nation number
four in California number number you
know I'm saying [ __ ] like that so we've
been building man shout out to my whole
chapter shout out to my parents my
coaches my staff and my kids they love
I'm talking about I got cheap kids Chief
babies they don't want to be nothing
else because in this new Dan air in this
new you football
everybody want to combine and join
forces it's kind of like the rap game
yeah when you hot they they messing with
you when you cold they not so you got
parents that's like well y'all don't win
I ain't I'm taking my baby somewhere
else you're not teaching the kids
nothing all right yeah I teach them how
to push through adversity you get better
and I got parents that's been with me
since we're taking them ass whoopings
and then we just added more kids we not
a chapter either that accept all the
great kids I might accept all alignments
but skills I don't want I want to
develop the kids that I got and you got
a lot of you got a lot of hate in in the
football Society we ain't gonna go I can
imagine I can admit bro listen
especially on me I can imagine there
ain't nothing like uh
parents whose kids play sports they I
ain't gonna even lie to you bro the the
things that I see and the things that
I'm subjective to see I'll be sitting
there like and I'm I'm so indebted in it
because I love it like it's a passion
for me it's more of a piece it's more
leaving the streets when I get to
practice like um I love seeing my babies
like I love seeing my kids these are my
kids but you got so much hate that they
put on Joe Moses and it's just like
we've made so much of an impact these
last couple of years they gonna hate and
a lot of people are they not they're not
ready for that a lot of people in my
chapter be like man what's gonna be like
bro that's just we successful we got the
best chapter in California period
anybody will tell you anybody in youth
football there but like the Chiefs for
hands down family orientated the way
they move the way their parents are like
we got the best chapter and and chief
football what is the wildest [ __ ] you've
seen from a parent at a game
um
got a parent at a game because we always
see like viral videos of like parents
fighting or someone just there's a lot
of crazy [ __ ] going on yeah probably
fighting you know what I'm saying
fighting I've seen I've seen teams lose
and parents fight each other I've seen
I've seen a lot in youth football like I
won't go really into it because I don't
want to put a bad stigma on you for you
football especially in in the chapter
that win that's why I feel it's more of
a family orientated like you take a loss
we'll be in the parking lot still
popping you know but outside of that
outside of that's where I feel right no
disrespect to nobody else I'm just not
as passionate for outside of syfl like I
love that's why I fail I'm all for syfl
Snoop you with snooze has done for me I
will never you know I'm saying never
leave his side I would never try to
start my own like he's done a lot for me
and always giving me the game and wisdom
and always you know everybody else like
I got love for everybody else outside of
Snoop but the family orientated outside
of snoopers like chaos oh really yeah
man yeah outside of Snoop you know I'm
just being honest with you it's like
okay it's like chaotic like everybody's
like every man for themselves and that's
not like you know I'm saying I'm for the
kids you know what I'm saying and I'm
passionate about it like if you your son
was on my team and you leave my team I
might not talk to you for six months
Jesus I'm just passionate about my kids
and and I built my kid it's a difference
when you build your kids right like I
built I built like you get you football
nails like you build a kid and as you
building a kid it's like they get the
success and then and then another
another coach might see them now but
they're on a better team and come on
over here come on over here and because
we're losing over here it's like I built
this kid nobody believed in this kid
like I built this kid now all of a
sudden you want to take the kids away
from me you know what I'm saying so it's
kind of bad it's kind of bad but it's a
great thing I can imagine I'll be
stressed out